Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen. Guten Morgen, Tim.
Sag mal, hast du nicht noch irgendwo eine heilige Kuh im Keller, die man mal schlachten könnte?
Ich finde es gut, dass wir Freunde sind, Tim. Oh ja, lass uns schlachten gehen.
Ich finde ja unser Intro hat auch so ein bisschen Dance Quality, oder? Also so ein kleiner Remix für den Dancefloor.
Immer gern gesehen.
Könnte, könnte den Clubs dieser Stadt nochmal ein bisschen Auftrieb verleihen.
Ja, ich will auch vor allem endlich mal mit so einem, mit so einem so einem DJ-Leben führen, weißt du? Dass du dann da reingehst, mit so einem großen Koffer. Alle denken, da wären Platten drin.
Sag mal, hast du doch Wackersteinerei getan.
Wie viel kann man ja alles Mögliche reintun.
Goldbarren. Ja. Ja, so ist das auch.
Ja. Und dann äh bist du der DJ. King. Alle tanzen. Du stehst da rum.
Die ganze Zeit im Lärm und bis in die Puppen, dich irgendwie in Sauerstoffarmbereichen bewegen.
Und dann wird dann zurück in Jet. Ibiza DJ. Ich würde ja nur in warmen Regionen machen.
Sagt ja, die fliegen auch alle nur easyJet.
Gegen Easyjet?
Lass uns mal lieber beim Podcast bleiben. Ich glaube, das liegt uns mehr.
Ja, hier ist Lokbuch Netzpolitik. Äh Ausgabe Nummer einhundert äh zweiundsechzig äh direkt live aus der äh Meterebene, ne.
Immer nur Meterebene. Das will ich zum Beispiel auch schade, dass man nicht das, wenn ich so einen Jetsetter leben für den Podcast. Heute live aus Ibiza.
Mainz heute aus äh aus Mallorca so genau. Sommergartenmäßig.
Der Thomas Gottschalk. Kriegt das auch hin oder hat er's hinbekommen? Wer hat denn das auf Mallorca oder sowas?
Ja, also ich sage mal, wenn da die entsprechenden äh Angebote kommen und die Leute bereit sind, unsere Wackersteine in Rollkoffern durch die Gegend zu.
Ja, wenn, also wir warten auf die Angebote der Clubs. Ibiza, Mallorca und so.
Aber wir haben ja auch gemerkt, Live-Situationen stellen andere Anforderungen an das Format, als die, die wir hier so ohne Weiteres äh erfüllen können.
Ich bin da durchaus bereit, ähm an Konzepten zu arbeiten. Aber erstmal müssen die erstmal müssen halt die Einladungen.
Muss bloß erstmal ein Versprechen im Raum stehen. Also überbieten sie sich jetzt. Unsere Leitungen sind jetzt freigeschaltet.
Netzpolitik, live aus Sydney.
Genau, rufen sie jetzt die Nummer neben ihrer Landesflagge an? Naja.
Ist schon wieder viel zu äh früh wohl und unterhaltsam hier. Lasst uns, lass uns zu den traurigen Themen kommen.
Ja. Ja, lass uns hier die Stimmung versauen.
Beginnen wir mit ein wenig äh Feedback zu dem äh frischen Thema der letzten Woche, was ich äh erst zehn Minuten so vor der Sendung überhaupt noch ins Programm reingeschoben hat,
obwohl so richtig neu ist, gibt's nicht so den geplanten oder noch nicht geplanten, aber zumindest vom BGH in einer Pressemitteilung in Aussicht gestellten matchbaren äh die halt,
Nach Ansicht des BGH nun mehr möglich sein sollen können,
Ähm das Urteil selber ist noch nicht veröffentlicht worden, oder?
Ich hab's zumindest noch nicht gefunden.
Fragt man sich, warum die überhaupt so früh äh in der Pressemitteilung rausgehen?
Ja, vielleicht um.
Das überlegen sie noch.
Um das Strohfeuer schon mal abzubrennen.
Aha. Na toll.
Ich finde, ja, ich habe also zumindest bis, als ich letzte Woche noch geschaut habe, habe ich nur diese die Meldungen.
Wir das machen würden. Pressemitteilung, noch Buchnetzpolitik wird.
Entscheidung, ja, bei beiden steht's, diese Entscheidung liegt am Bundesgerichtshof noch nicht gedruckt vor, sobald sie gedruckt vorliegen wird, werden sie sie an dieser Stelle finden.
Müssen noch ein paar Bäume umbringen vorher.
Ich finde witzig, wie die äh sind noch dran, eine Idee. Die entscheidet haben wir haben sie nur noch nicht zu Papier gefasst.
Und warte nicht auf Papier ist, das gibt es auch nicht.
Ja, keine Ahnung. Aber du wolltest noch äh auf das Interview mit dem.
Genau, es gab bei Logbuch äh bei Netzpolitik Punkt org gab's ein Interview, was Konstanze äh kurz geführt hat mit ähm jetzt habe ich den Namen mir nicht notiert.
Ansgar Coring.
Genau. Ähm wie denn das Ganze äh auf äh nach Gutachten dieser Pressemitteilung denn zu beurteilen sei.
Und äh im Wesentlichen habe ich aus diesem Interview herausgelesen,
Skepsis, die wir hier eigentlich auch schon gehabt haben. Vor allem im Hinblick da drauf, dass er eben äh Incopatibilitäten sieht mit dieser Entscheidung und,
bisher geltenden Regelungen für Exzess-Provider, wie sie im Telemedien,
festgehalten sind, insbesondere so im Hinblick auf Datensparsamkeit,
und äh das halt auch es wirklich unklar sei, wie denn eine solche technische Umsetzung ähm,
Vorzunehmen sei, darüber würde halt nix gesagt werden und dass er eben auch der Meinung ist, dass eigentlich die bisher bekannten ähm,
technischen Lösungen für so etwas, was so bekannt ist, was ja so derzeit überall diskutiert, teilweise leider auch umgesetzt wird
einfach 'ne ganze Menge Kollateralschaden mit sich bringt, da haben wir auch schon letztes Mal drüber diskutiert, nicht wahr? Also das Problem des Overblockings, dass einfach legale Angebote vom Netz genommen werden, wo mit denen ja im Prinzip auch.
Äh die Rechte genommen werden oder ihre Rechte verletzt werden,
Weil ist ja nicht deine Schuld, dass jemand anders äh etwas Illegales tut und wenn jetzt eine solche Maßnahme ergriffen wird, die dann eben auf dein Angebot eine Auswirkung hat, dann ist das natürlich nicht rechts und von daher äh im Prinzip auch anfechtbar.
Beziehungsweise wenn's eben um so Sachen geht wie die Inspection, also dass die Datenströme so im Detail analysiert werden,
um sozusagen herauszufinden, ob du nun wirklich das ähm angeblich,
Illegale Angebot ähm versucht wird, zu erreichen oder eben ein legales, dass man in dem Fall halt dagegen äh verstößt gegen die, ja,
Nicht Überwachung dieser Datenströme. Und das sei halt einfach alles schwierig.
Gibt dann auch noch ein schönes Beispiel, was gerade ähm bekannt geworden ist,
in Österreich, wo es eine ja, ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir das schon mal diskutiert haben über die dort herrschende äh Netzsperrenregelung.
Haben wir damals, als das Urteil war.
Ja und hat ja nicht mehr alles im Kopf,
Auf jeden Fall gibt's hier den schönen Fall, dass eben dort äh tatsächlich Pirate Bay mal wieder blockiert werden soll und das wurde dann von einem österreichischen Provider umgesetzt,
aber dann eben teilweise auch Data-Center in der Slowakei hat, also dort Standorte hat
und in seinem ja administrativen Vorgehen dieses Detail an der Stelle nicht äh berücksichtigt hat und in dem Fall eben die Netzsperren dann auch in der Slowakei durchgesetzt hat, obwohl
ist dort keine entsprechende rechtliche Basis gibt oder vielleicht gibt es die auch weiß ich nicht aber auf jeden Fall gab's keine äh Entscheidung,
schon gar nicht das in dem Moment, wo das in Österreich so ist, ist automatisch in der Slowakei genauso äh vorzunehmen ist. Da sieht man mal wieder schön, auf was für einen wackeligen,
Grund, solche Regelungen stehen und ähm die Debatte geht weiter bevor allerdings jetzt dieses Gesetz.
Also diese Gerichtsentscheidung veröffentlicht ist, denke ich mal, dort werden wir hier nur ein wenig in der Luft herum und,
eigentlich gar nichts finales dazu sagen. Ne? Das mal so als Nachtrag.
Dann wollen wir uns wollen wir uns aber doch noch ein bisschen den Urhebern widmen, oder Tim?
Ja, das ist ja unser Lieblingsthema, oder?
Ja, die müssen ja auch mal irgendwie vergütet werden. Also die Urheber jetzt gar nicht unbedingt, sondern eher so die Inhaber an die, die ihre Rechte abgetreten haben, habe ich so ein bisschen den Eindruck, oder?
Ja, ja. Das auch. Auf jeden Fall sind sie ja bei alle zusammengekommen. Ich muss eine tolle Party gewesen sein. Fünfzig Jahre Urheberrecht in Deutschland.
Schön fand ich auch, dass die Konferenz, also fünfzig Jahre Urheberrecht, in Deutschland war der Untertitel. Der Titel war die Zukunft des Urheberrechts, wobei sie das lustigerweise in Erfurts schreiben,
fand statt am Anfang äh dieses Monats, erster und zweiter Dezember in Berlin und wurde äh von der Initiative Urheberrecht,
Das ist so ein Zusammenschluss von fünfunddreißig Verbinden aller Art, also in so diverse Komponisten, Musiker, Verbände drin, also Autoren,
aber halt auch so, wer hat die DGB,
eine äh illustre Liste, also im Prinzip so ein bisschen so die Urheberrechtslobby und sie haben dann auch alles äh eingeladen, was äh da äh Rang und Namen hat,
auch ein paar kritische Töne. Na ja und das war so ein bisschen so ein Rundumschlag, also dort haben sie äh,
offensichtlich eine Debatte geführt, die sehr in diese Richtung geht. Na ja, wir brauchen jetzt mal irgendwie eine neue Regelung im Internet, eine neue Art von Internetvergütung. Da gab's dann einen Matthias Leistner,
Professor für geistiges Eigentum, das ist für sowas sogar schon Professorenstellen gibt, interessant, ne?
Ja, man sei ja irgendwie bei pauschalen Zahlungen irgendwie äh äh eigentlich ja eher skeptisch, aber online könnte man ja damit einen Ausgleich schaffen. Das ist sozusagen diese Debatte dieser permanenten Unzufriedenheit mit allem.
Ähm,
Wo ich mich halt frage so, okay, was ist jetzt so mit den Pauschalabgaben bei Kopierern und äh anderen Geräten, die es seit ewigen Zeiten gibt und äh wo ja durchaus eklektische Summen erzeugt werden, sind die jetzt sozusagen,
Ja
Aber na ja, eine Kulturflatrate, so wollte man ja nur auch nicht haben, nicht? Also was sozusagen so alles über einen Kamm schert, sondern man bräuchtet ja, wie es so schön heißt, Problemspezifische Lösungen. Und insbesondere so für Zusatzdienste, wie
Suchmaschinen-Newsagretoren und Anbieter ähnlicher Geschäftsmodelle, ja?
Nachtigall, ich höre dir äh trapsen. Da haben wir also wieder die Leistungsschutzrecht äh Debatte. Das finden sie ja immer noch ganz toll, weil das würde ja Rechtssicherheit schaffen für die Plattform und die Privatpersonen, also wäre sozusagen so eine Rundumlösung,
In Bedding wäre dann zwar ein bisschen schwierig äh äh ohne so eine Lösung und deswegen müsste man ja sozusagen,
sowas da einführen. Also überhaupt so dieses Plattform stärker in die Verantwortung nehmen, ist halt so dieses Gejammere rund um YouTube und äh andere Plattformen, so die wollen sozusagen einfach da,
für die Nutzung von allem möglichen Anteile bekommen. Und ist ganz interessant, dass,
auch dann in einer anderen äh Debatte.
Äh außerdem Netz unterstellt wird. Da würden ja irgendwie auch nur die Werbemodelle äh funktionieren. Muss ich gleich noch zu,
Linda Dobrosch, der auch für Netzpolitik Ork schreibt, war auch vor Ort und,
meinte so, naja, so ein äh kollektive Rechteverwertung wäre ja mal durchaus ganz äh sinnvoll, aber äh wenn, dann bitte eben auch mit einer Steigerung der Nutzerrechte, weil das ist ja nun derzeit auch immer wieder ein Problem,
einfach überhaupt nicht mehr weiß, wie man mit Inhalten umgeht und wenn sie dann also pauschale
Vergütungsmodelle anstreben, welcher Art auch immer, dann sollte man sozusagen das auch mal in Richtung äh Nutzer, dass man eben diese Inhalte auch einfacher nutzen kann und dann weniger Fallen reinläuft,
ähm ja, hat er sozusagen angemahnt. Uns würde es irgendwie der Urheberlobby auch irgendwie am Ende viel zu viele,
Urteile, weitere Urteile einbringen, die sie irgendwie auch nicht glücklich machen.
Das war sozusagen so dieser eine Tenor, der von dieser Veranstaltung so etwas abstrahlte.
Ja, das andere ist, dass ja sozusagen jetzt noch nochmal einen neuen Feind ausgemacht haben und zwar ahnt's es schon, die Anonymität,
ja, Anonymität, die steht ja irgendwie immer äh hinter der Straßenecke mit einer Keule in der Hand und bedroht uns.
Hier wurde es dann als heilige Kuh der Nerds bezeichnet,
die mal geschlachtet gehört. Mhm. So eine Formulierung äh soll es dort gegeben haben und äh die kam von einem Göttinger Medienrechtler namens Gerald Spindler,
und überhaupt diese ganze Anonymität wäre total überbewertet und es sei ja auch gar kein Grundrecht, steht ja nicht im Grundgesetz, sonst gäbe ja auch keine Bundesverfassungsgerichtsentscheidung et cetera PP
sowas würde ja irgendwie nur im äh Telemediengesetz äh festgeschrieben sein und äh da müsste man doch sozusagen mal ein paar äh entsprechende,
Anpassungen machen. Das gelte auch für die auf EU äh Ebene ausgegebene E-Commerce-Richtlinie,
Anonymität hätten wir gerne mal weg weil man muss ja sozusagen,
Kann ja nicht sein, dass dass man irgendwie anonym ist und nichts nachvollziehbar ist. Und äh wenn denn überhaupt diese Haftungsprivilegien der Anbieter erhalten bleiben soll, also wenn sozusagen äh,
Provider anonymen Zugang zu Netzen ermöglichen, ja, wie zum Beispiel auch, ne, die Debatte hatten wir ja auch schon mit Freifunk,
Ja dann doch bitte nur mit automatisierter Rechtsverfolgung auf Basis irgendeines ID Systems.
Also du bist nur du du hast nur Haftungsprivileg, wenn du einen automatisierten.
Automatisierte.
Verfolgung aller deiner Nutzer.
Ja, genau, weil wenn man dann mal, ne, wenn ja mal sein will, was nicht stimmt, wie es so schön heißt.
Also diese diese Urheberrechtsleute, ne, die sind sowas von bescheuert. Also ich meine, das ist so ein Thema.
Was man ja auch immer mal wieder, also,
Was man vielleicht nach so einer Zeit auch irgendwie mal belächeln muss, ja? Ich meine, die haben es in Jahrzehnten nicht auf die Kette gekriegt,
Ihr beschissenes Geschäftsmodell, was von vorne herein nicht moralisch war?
Zu retten. Es geht ja hier eben nicht um Menschen. Es geht ja hier, hier stehen ja nicht Leute, mit einer Gitarre, die sagen, Scheiße, ich ich spiele mir die Finger blutig und kann die Miete nicht bezahlen.
Sondern es geht hier um Leute, die Millionen umsetzen mit dem kreativen Schaffen anderer. Ja? Und die früher einmal,
ein ein Geschäftsmodell hatten,
weil sie einem Musiker sagen konnten, na ja, guck mal, wenn du eine CD machen möchtest, ne, da musst du die ja auch in die Läden bringen, da musst du die produzieren. Da brauchst du einen finanziellen Vorschuss, um die um
in Vorleistung zu treten und all das nehmen wir dir ab. Wir geben dir im Prinzip Vorschuss, Kredit,
in die Produktion deines Werkes. Wir haben eine Vertriebsinfrastruktur, wir sorgen dafür, dass das Ding irgendwie in realistischen Zahlen in in jedem CD-Laden irgendwo liegt. Wir nehmen dir all dieses all das ab.
Und dann haben sie irgendwann natürlich dafür immer mehr Geld genommen,
oder immer mehr Anteil, ja? Und haben es quasi Musikern, die irgendwie sagten, ja okay, ich möchte jetzt aber irgendwie die,
hoffentlich bei einem großen Label unter Vertrag sein und und dick im Business sein, den haben sie, den haben sie natürlich am Anfang schon irgendwelche harten Verträge gegeben
um die dann möglichst an sich zu binden und zu melden. Ja, das sind auch schon Geschichten, keine Ahnung, die haben ja schon, weiß ich nicht, die die Beatles hatten das Problem ja schon, bevor sie dann irgendwann ihre eigenen, äh ihr eigenes Label gemacht haben,
vielleicht auch nicht. So, dann ähm diese, diese Industrie, ja,
ist seit seit fünfzehn, zwanzig Jahren jetzt mit der Existenz der digitalen Kopie und des Internets,
konfrontiert. Und ihnen ist nichts eingefallen, gar nichts um irgendwie mal ihr Modell, ihre Dienstleistung, ihr Angebot an Künstler und Gesellschaft in irgendeiner Form.
Oder für überhaupt mal an die Nutzer.
Genau. An irgendjemanden ihren Wertbeitrag gegenüber,
irgendjemanden außer sich selber mal äh an diese neuen äh Gegebenheiten anzupassen. So, es kommen,
Es kommt am Ende irgendwie völlig verspätet.
Kommt dann irgendein US-Startup daher und sagt, ach hier komm, ey, dann machen wir jetzt Spotify,
und dann irgendwie jo Napster. So und diese Ideen, die das hätten die alles haben können. Und und statt die einfach selber umzusetzen, führen sie,
jahrelange äh rechtliche Auseinandersetzung mit diesen ganzen Stores und bremsen die aus. So und jetzt irgendwie, jetzt geht Apple hin und sagt so, zack und wir sind jetzt endlich an dem Punkt,
Dass man sagt, okay, komm. Zehner aufm Tisch, Musik-Flat.
Ja? Und es es bleibt nur noch das Problem, wie Scheiße die Einkünfte, nämlich in diesen Verwertungsorganisationen wie GEMA und so weiter verteilt werden, wo äh wo wir wissen, dass da eben die die ähm
die die Verteilung der Einkünfte nach oben läuft und zum Nachteil der Musiker ist, die eigentlich gefördert werden müssten
Ja und denen fällt nichts ein, außer am Ende sich noch zweitausendfünfzehn, ja, in einer Welt von von Spotify, Apple Music, Netflix,
Ja, die,
die die Antworten des Marktes hatten, ja? Netflix hat gesagt, okay, komm, dieser ganze Pirate Scheiß macht keinen Spaß, gibt uns einen Zehner oder oder es kostet ja noch nicht mal einen Zehner, gibt uns soundso viel Geld, wir produzieren sogar noch eigene Serien für euch.
Linus, das siehst du vollkommen falsch,
Dieter Gorni äh hat ja auch gesagt auf dieser Veranstaltung äh im im Netz gäbe es ja eigentlich nur Werbung und keine wirklich neuen Geschäftsmodelle,
Und diese ganze Haftungs äh Privilegierung, also diese ganze Einschränkung des Urheberrechts, die man bisher gestattet hätte
Das sei ja sozusagen nur eine einseitige Freistellung gewesen, quasi als Entwicklungshilfe für das Internet. Man habe es jetzt mal ein wenig so laufen lassen, aber jetzt müsse ja auch mal äh Schluss sein, so frei nach
Jetzt habt ihr sozusagen eure Businessmodelle alle schön entwickelt, jetzt wollen wir mal ähm sozusagen mitverdienen, weil es wäre ja alles nur möglich gewesen, weil die Urheberrechts ähm orientierten Menschen, sie haben freilaufen lassen,
Da müsste man jetzt mal rational über einen neuen Rechtsrahmen reden.
Idiot. Das ist einfach so, die haben einfach keine äh die haben einfach keine Visionen. Die haben einfach die,
merken nicht, was da draußen los ist. Das ist auch das ist auch dramatisch für diese Branche, das muss man ja auch sehen. Äh ich meine,
Du stellst die Leute stellen sich doch hin und werfen das werfen denen Geld entgegen,
wenn sie eine Möglichkeit dazu bekommen. Aber diese Leute sind doch mit an nichts anderem interessiert, als inzwischen genau diese Rechtsdurchsetzung, sprich Abmahnungen als Geschäftsmodell zu fahren. Machen wir uns da doch nix vor,
Ja, die diese Äußerungen, die sie da ähm die sie da haben,
diese Ziele mit keiner Anonymität mehr automatisierte Rechtssicherung,
zeigen ja genau das, dass sie im Prinzip das Geschäftsmodell der Abmahnung äh sichern wollen. Also die haben einfach die,
Ich würde mich, also die sind einfach unglaublich schlecht beraten und das ist so richtig altes Eisen und Leute, die die mit mit.
Klingen und, und, und Waffen, ein Geschäftsmodell verteidigen wollen, was untergeht. Und es ist gut, dass das untergeht. Und es ist gut,
dass Musiker sich inzwischen selber vermarkten, selber vertreiben können und nicht mehr daran gebunden sind. Dieser ganze Kram, das Musiker gefangen wurden von den Labels. Der einzige Grund für all diese Verwertungsketten, die die Labels da aufgemacht haben, war, dass
das Tonträger,
dass Musik an physikalische Tonträger gebunden war und dass du damit Produktionskosten für diese Tonträger hast, Lagerkosten und Verteilungsproblemen. Und das ist alles weg,
und es gibt keinen Grund mehr, dass es Labels gibt und deshalb sollen die jetzt bitte einfach abschmieren.
Und leider Gottes werden sie dann ersetzt werden durch durch Apple Music und Spotify,
das Problem daran ist natürlich, dass wir das auch nicht gut finden, weil wir da den nächsten großen äh Kapitalriesen haben, der äh quasi monopolistisch sich irgendwie diesen Markt aufteilt. Und das ist
natürlich auch scheiße, deswegen wollten wir ja immer und deswegen haben wir immer
propagiert, eben, weil sie nicht eine direktes Verhältnis zwischen Musiker und ähm und Künstlern möglichst konkretischen,
direkte Bezahlungsmodelle, zum Beispiel Flatter, zum Beispiel Spenden oder sonst was, um diese zentralistischen Infrastrukturen irgendwie aufzubrechen, aber äh das haben wir jetzt offenbar wahrscheinlich nicht geschafft,
Aber es ist irgendwie eine dramatisch, dass die die, die, die, die scheidende, zentralistische äh Infrastruktur, die den Markt umklammert hat
da jetzt irgendwie seit zehn Jahren immer noch genug Geld hat, solche Veranstaltungen zu durchzuziehen und irgendwie Grundrechtseinschränkungen und Hasse nicht gesehen zu fordern. Für die Durchsetzung eines Einzelnen
beschissenen Geschäftsmodells auf dieser Welt, als wenn wir keine anderen hätten.
Also die Stimme nicht ganz zu, was äh sozusagen Sinn und Aufgabe von Labels betrifft, weil dieser äh Tonträger gebundene Teil, der war natürlich
klar äh stand im Vordergrund, aber ist ja nicht so, dass es jetzt sozusagen keinerlei Dienstleistungen gäbe, die Musiker von Labels nicht auch noch erfahren könnten, also im Bereich irgendwie Entwicklung, Marketing, äh Vertrieb et cetera, gibt's ja durchaus auch äh Möglichkeiten,
Bin ich jetzt im Einzelnen gar nicht so ähm nochmal aufdröseln. Sondern ich wollte nochmal kurz zurückkommen auf.
Vor allem diesen Punkt, dass sie jetzt gegen Anonymität sind, weil das finde ich einfach überhaupt so, dass äh,
Das größte Problem dieser ganzen Urheberrechtsdebatte ist, dass hier wirklich sehr einseitig das äh alles bewertet wird. Ne, also alles, was was irgendwie ihre geschäftlichen ähm,
Ausdehnungspläne und äh in gewisser Hinsicht auch ihre ihre äh wirtschaftliche Faulheit,
bedient, weil sie wollen es ja selber irgendwie nicht wirklich kreatives einfallen lassen, sondern warten sozusagen, ne? Haftungs einseitige Freistellung für schöne Formulierung. Eine einseitige Freistellung nach dem Motto, ja, ihr ihr macht jetzt mal,
Wir haben ja das Recht,
und wenn wir der Meinung sind, der Zeitpunkt ist gekommen und jetzt äh ist er offensichtlich gekommen, dann äh hauen wir zu und dazu sind uns einfach auch alle Mittel recht, insbesondere äh kassieren wir dann eben gerne auch mal so äh Rechte, die, na ja, vielleicht,
Nicht im Grundgesetz, also was nicht im Grundgesetz steht, das kann man sowieso schon mal weghauen. Und Anonymität ist natürlich jetzt sozusagen äh super äh Ding, ne. Hier kommen dann auch super Vergleiche. Matthias Lausen.
Institut für Urheber und Medienrecht, da gibt's da so einige irgendwie. Kann man so hinten Urheberrecht und nimmst alle Top-Level Domains, dann hast du mal ein Institut nach dem anderen,
Die der der schließt nämlich auch in das selbe Horn. Ja, weil äh schöner Vergleich, Anonymität sei ja im realen Leben auch nicht äh wirklich überall da
es gäbe ja Vermummungsverbot und äh man hätte ja auch so Verantwortliche im Sinne des Presserechts, wenn man irgendwie eine Zeitung veröffentlicht und so weiter und so fort.
Und ähm.
Ja, die Bundesregierung sollte doch mal jetzt äh durch eine Änderung im TMG da äh eine Vorlage machen, um der EU Beine zu machen. Also sie sehen auch sozusagen schon die Problematik, dass das Ganze ja hier auf EU-Ebene im Wesentlichen sich einig entscheidet. Klingt für mich jetzt auch so ein bisschen hilflos.
Und das ist halt wirklich ein Problem. Und dann haben sie sich irgendwie auch noch die äh noch einen ganz progressiven Teil äh in unserer Gesellschaft eingeladen. Renate Künast war nämlich auch noch da, ja,
mit dem äh Blick äh der Zukunft zugewandt.
Meinte er, gerade im Hinblick auf Anonymität, das wäre überhaupt ganz schlimm, weil man muss ja nur mal ins Netz gucken, da werden ja irgendwie Rüdebeschimpfungen anders an der Tagesordnung,
und überhaupt diese ganze Anonymität wäre ja total böse, fügt aber auch noch hinzu, dass sie offensichtlich in ihrer Fraktion da relativ alleine da steht,
ja kein Wunder Renate, weil äh guck dir mal die Rüdenbeschimpfungen jetzt an. Ja, wenn die mal so anonym wären, ja, äh,
schlägst du mal dein Facebook morgens auf und äh da hast du halt die ganzen mit äh voller Name und äh Wohnort und Pipapo und Babyfotos
Also äh dass das sozusagen kausale Zusammenhänge ist, das lässt sich auf jeden Fall ganz amtlich wegdiskutieren. Sicherlich,
Gibt es auch Anonymität als Verschleierung von Haterkultur, haben wir auch alles gesehen, aber dass das jetzt sozusagen ursächlich zusammenhängt, das kann man nun auch nicht sagen oder das Problem geht ein bisschen tiefer, beziehungsweise bewegt sich dann doch,
äh auf einer anderen Ebene.
Aber auf jeden Fall in dieser Urheberrechtsklinke da ist das irgendwie alles ganz klar. Sie würden sich halt ganz gerne an Werbeeinnahmen beteiligen und so, wo ich mich halt auch frage, was versucht denn YouTube seit Jahren anzubieten, ne? Ähm.
Die würden sich an allen Einnahmen gerne beteiligen. Ich auch, bin ich ganz ehrlich, ich würde auch mich an einigen Einnahmen, die es auf dieser Welt gibt, durchaus gerne beteiligen,
und sehe da äh auch äh durchaus Bereitschaft von meiner Seite äh auf äh den Gesetzgeber zuzugehen, ja.
Ja, ich habe auch Apple, Apple geschrieben, dass er irgendwie jetzt mal, ich fordere einen Prozent.
Ich fordere ein.
Ja, das war nur eine einseitige Freistellung von mir, dass sie sozusagen ohne mich zu beteiligen. Da äh,
wirtschaften können, aber jetzt nachdem ich ihn einfach auch durch äh Zuspruch und aktiven Fanboysen, der mir äh redlich unterstellt wird, ja, also wenn das mir schon unterstellt wird, dann muss ich das ja auch ausnutzen können. Also.
Vor allem ist das auch einfach mal mein Geschäftsmodell ist einfach, dass Apple nicht mit ein Prozent am Umsatz beteiligt.
So und jetzt musste, das muss der Gesetzgeber einfach mal umsetzen.
Genau, das stimmt, das können wir einfach, wenn wir in der EU-Richtlinie einfach mal festschreiben, ne.
So, ich finde es, sonst stirbt die Sandpakt.
Genau, mein Markt stirbt.
Markt stirbt und das ist ja wohl das ist Staatsversagen, das ist Staatsversagen.
Hilfe! Hilfe! Ja, am Ende hört keiner mehr meine Podcasts, ja? Also, wo kommen wir denn da hin? Ja, ja, ja.
Es ist echt witzig. In einer Welt, die sonst keine Probleme hat.
Genau. Wir haben schöne äh Links für euch auf Berichte von dieser unsäglichen Konferenz.
Na ja.
Ah ja, genau, ich habe noch ein Video dazu getan. Ähm beim,
netzpolitischen Abend der digitalen Gesellschaft hat der Volker Tripp einen kleinen Vortrag gehalten,
ähm der, glaube ich, der, ich glaube, die offizielle Position ist politischer Referent, der war in ähm,
in äh Karlsruhe und hat da äh vorm Bundesverfassungsgericht als Sachverständiger äh gesprochen. Da ging's irgendwie um.
Die Idee des Sampling, die da vor Gericht verhandelt wurde. Ja, es war auch nochmal sehr interessant, weil Volker ja Jurist ist, wie der auch da nochmal bisschen Gesetzestexte auseinander nimmt und so, dass ähm,
empfehle ich einfach mal auch so als äh als Video, wer wer sich noch ein bisschen mit Urheberrechtsargumentation auseinandersetzen möchte.
Ja, kommen wir zu den wirklich wichtigen Problemen dieser Welt.
Tim, ich finde es gut, dass wir ein wirklich wichtiges Problem haben. Was ist es denn?
Was ist das denn? Du sagst mir immer alles nach und zeichnest das auf.
Findest du es gut, wenn ich alles nachsage und aufzeichne?
Die Hello Barbie.
Ja, Spielzeuge werden ja eh jetzt auch smart. Würde ich mal sagen, ne? Also ich glaube überhaupt, dass das Unwort des äh Jahrhunderts,
ist dieses dieser Dekade ist. Smart, bei Smartphones lasse ich's gerade noch durchgehen, aber äh der Rest, so wie Smart TVs und so weiter führt irgendwie nur dazu, dass die ganze Zeit dich einfach überwachen,
diese Geräte. Das scheint irgendwie so Bild-In zu sein.
Zumindest bei den ähm,
Sachen, ne? Bei den Massenmarktgeschichten. Ähm ich habe da ja vor einiger Zeit schon ähm mal so ein Buchkapitel zugeschrieben, hatte ich hier glaube ich auch mal drauf hingewiesen,
zu dieser ganzen Internet of Things Geschichte,
wo ich eigentlich hauptsächlich argumentiere, dass es eben nicht ein Internet der Dinge ist, sondern dass diese Dinge einfach nur Sensoren der Cloud sind. Ja, das Ding ist nicht smart, sondern die Cloud, die dahinter hängt und das fernbedient,
simuliert dir ein smartes Ding. Es gab jetzt auch vor kurzem diesen Spiegel Artikel, glaube ich, mit ähm Heiko Maas, der da irgendwie seine ganze Bude äh smart gemacht hat mit irgendwie einer Glühbirne, die,
Sorry, sorry, Heiko.
Wissen wir, wissen wir noch nicht, wie smart äh das bei ihnen zu Hause ist.
Da halte ich es mit der äh wahrscheinlich da hält sich das in Grenzen, aber die ähm Heiko Maas hat einmal alles so in diesem Artikel. Mike Marco Maas.
War hier auch schon mal zu Gast. Ja, ja.
Ich weiß, im ganz im Gegensatz zu Heiko Maas, den sollten wir vielleicht mal vielleicht auch mal fragen.
Genau, genau. Zeig mir deine Barbie und ich sage dir, wie du.
Ja, wenn er nächstes Jahr mit dem Staatstrojaner um die Ecke kommt, äh bieten wir ihm hier einen Slot an, aber er kennt ja auch unser Geschäftsmodell. Mal gucken, ob er sich.
Du hast durchgesetzt bekommt.
Also, smart, smart Bude. So und dann hat gibt es irgendwie von Philipp so Glühbirnen und ich glaube, da war so die Rede von so einem MB oder sowas, was die umsetzen. An Daten ins Internet. Auch wenn du nicht da bist. Ich.
Auch wenn du nicht da bist. Die Glühbirnen. Ach echt diese Dinger.
Irgend so eine Glühbirne. Ich habe das jetzt auch nicht im Detail verfolgt. Ähm.
So, also diese Fakt ist, diese Geräte sind äh sehr gesprächig und es ist nicht korrekt zu sagen, dass diese Geräte ein Internet bilden, weil die Geräte sprechen immer nur mit zu Hause.
Wenn irgendwann die Situation kommt, dass von mir aus deine,
Dein Kühlschrank mit der Waschmaschine redet, dann reden die nicht direkt miteinander, sondern die reden über die Cloud miteinander. Das heißt, da sind immer große Serverfarmen hinter.
Personenwagen sind da auch ganz weit vorne.
Personenwagen.
Ja klar, stellt sich da morgens drauf und dann messen die ja irgendwie alles, lassen da Strom durch dich durchlaufen und fühlen dein Inneres ich und das wird dann abgespeichert.
Dann wird dein inneres Ich in die Cloud hochgeladen,
So und jetzt hatten ja die Idee, ähm hatte Mathe die Idee zusammen mit Toi Talk,
Eine Barbie rauszubringen, die mit dir spricht. Und ähm,
Ist ein Unternehmen, was so äh Spracherkennungskram macht. Die haben auch schon vorher so Apps gehabt, konntest dir eine App runterladen und dann war aufm Bildschirm irgendwie, was weiß ich, ein Krokodil oder ein lustiger äh lustiger Affe oder so, mit denen man zu reden. Er hat ja auch geantwortet, ja.
Also sprach äh Analyse, Sprachsynthese und irgendwie die Dinger merken sich natürlich auch was von dir und sagen dann, hey, ich erinnere mich, dass du mir erzählt hast, dass du eine Schwester hast. Äh wie findest du deine Schwester? Na, irgendwie solche Scherze, ne? Und
dahinter verbirgt sich halt so 'ne große Spracherkennung, Sprachsynthese-Cloud, ähnlich wie Siri, eigentlich genau das gleiche.
Ähm und Mathe,
der Hersteller der Barbie hat sich halt mit Toi Talk zusammengeschlossen, hat gesagt, ey pass auf, lass uns doch mal,
Statt ihr mit euren Apps, lasst uns doch mal eine Barbie-Puppe machen, die das kann. Dann kriegt ihr halt eine Barbiestimme und ähm wenn man der auf den Bauch drückt und was sagt, dann macht das klonk und dann so eine Siri Barbie im Prinzip, ne. Nur mit dem,
Mit dem Ziel oder mit dem konkreten Anwendungszweck, dass sich eben die Kinder mit dieser Puppe unterhalten.
Ja und ähm bei den Big Brother Awards dieses Jahr habe ich die Laudatio dafür gehalten, weil wir dieser äh Barbie Puppe einen Big Brother Award gegeben haben,
weil sie junge Kinder,
jungen Kindern beibringt, unkritisch mit solchen Technologien umzugehen. Und,
noch darüber hinaus ähm Daten dieser Kinder natürlich speichert und zum Beispiel so Funktionen hat, dass die Eltern über einen über ihren Zugang,
alle Gespräche, die das Kind mit dieser Puppe geführt hat, nochmal anhören können.
Das Schlimme an diese an diesem Produkt ist, wenn die Eltern das nicht könnten, wäre es irgendwie auch unheimlich.
Aber wenn sie's können, auch, ja. Das ganze Produkt ist unheimlich und deswegen ist das eine eine nicht so eine gute Idee gewesen,
Und aber macht euch keine Sorgen, die Gespräche, die eure Kinder mit dieser Puppe führen, werden maximal für zwei Jahre auf den Servern gespeichert, länger nicht.
Du bist ja beruhigt.
Und äh so zu Werbezwecken werden die nicht missbraucht. Ja, also eine der Befürchtungen war natürlich auch, dass du, wenn du mal nicht im Raum bist, empfiehlt die Barbie halt deinem Kind, was es sich als nächstes wünschen soll, ne? Hast du schon mal den,
wunderbar, leckeren Schokoriegel-Rovierte. Frag mal die Mama.
Vielleicht hat sie noch so einen eher Empfänger drin und merkt, das kennen nicht in der Nähe ist. Oh, ich kann nicht mehr, ohne dich leben, wo es kennen.
Kennen ist halt, ja genau, also solche, genau.
Kind, still, meine Barbie stirbt. Solche Geschichten. Was werden wir noch alles erleben?
Solche Geschichten, ja? Und das werden wir noch alles erleben. Und in der Erwachsenenwelt haben wir es ja heute schon mit diesem Kindle. Ja, Kindle ist irgendwie ein Zwanni billiger, wenn der Werbung anzeigt.
Ah ja genau. Ah jetzt billiger mit Werbung und so.
Ab und zu mal eine kleine Produktempfehlung, die ist ja auch aber das ist ja noch Zukunftsmusik. In.
Eine Logbuch Netzpolitik Barbie rausbringen, die die ganze Kinder schon frühzeitig auf die netzpolitischen Probleme hinweist.
Morgen Barbie.
Nee, äh genau, die heißt Hello Barbie und wir machen einen guten Morgen, Tim.
Ähm so dann gab's halt natürlich, es gibt Datenschutz,
schwerwiegende Datenschutzprobleme mit solchen Geräten. Wenn man die Kindern in die Hand drückt, das ist ein bisschen creepy und ähm.
Ich weiß jetzt auch nicht genau, ob das unbedingt notwendig ist, dass die Kinder Puppen haben, die Antworten. Das müssen Eltern für für sich entscheiden. Aber dann kam natürlich auch sofort das Thema auf, kann man dat hacken?
Und kann man, natürlich kann man das. So und.
Du willst mir jetzt sagen, was bei so einem sensitiven Produkt nicht von vorne rein auf Sicherheit geachtet wurde.
Ähm es gibt einen US-Sicherheitsforscher, den, sage ich mal,
dessen Veröffentlichung ich ein bisschen fragwürdig finde, weil er nicht erklärt wie. Also er sagt, er war äh er war, er sei jetzt mit mit den Herstellern im Gespräch, um die.
Die Sicherheitslücken, die er ausgenutzt hat, zu beseitigen,
Aber er hat jetzt irgendwie nicht großartig erklärt, was er überhaupt getan hat. Zum Beispiel hat er noch nicht einmal erklärt, ob es sich um einen äh Remote-Angriff handelt oder um ein äh physikalischen Angriff auf dem,
Auf den Videos in der Artikel Bebilderung siehst du eine aufgemachte Barbie,
Was mich zu der reinen unbegründeten Spekulation verleitet, dass es vielleicht einen Hardwareangriff ist. Vielleicht hat die Flash-Speicher der Unverschlüsselt ist und er hat einfach den Flash-Bereich herausgelötet, ja? Also,
Unklar, was er da getan hat, aber er sagt, er konnte also er ist an die ähm,
Gespeicherte WiFi-Zugänge auf dieser Barbie, die hat ja WLAN äh und an MP3 Aufnahmen gelangt, die auf diesem Gerät gespeichert waren. Aber wie gesagt, er sagt nicht, wie er es getan hat und er sagt äh,
Es war nicht ganz so einfach und äh er sei jetzt mit den mit den Herstellern im Gespräch um diese Sicherheitslücken zu,
zu lösen. Insgesamt finde ich den so ein bisschen ähm diesen ganzen Auftritt so ein bisschen komisch, weil er dann auch sagt, er hätte die MAC-Adresse von der Barbie herausgefunden,
Wo ich mir so denke, natürlich, sie ist in deinem WLAN, also so das äh schwierig, schwierig, so dass.
Großartiges Haarkader.
Ja, also so ein bisschen äh bisschen unseriöse Darstellung dieses Problems und unseriöse.
Behandlung des Themas auch in den Medien. Aber äh es handelt sich,
das kann man wohl sagen, ein Angriff auf das Einzelgerät. Und viel spannender, was sich ja auch in dem in meinem kleinen äh Artikelchen geschrieben habe, viel schwangerer ist viel spannend. Der ist natürlich der Angriff auf die Cloud, die dahinter steckt,
Ja, also ich will nicht die Barbie angreifen.
Barbie Cloud.
Cloud, ja? Ähm,
Habe das, glaube ich, in dem Buch ungefähr in dem Buchartikel so geschrieben, so frei nach äh Berthold Brecht, was ist ein Einbruch in eine Bank gegen die Gründung einer Bank
Was ist dir, was ist der Einbruch in ein Fitnessarmband gegen die Gründung einer Fitness-Cloud? Ja? Und das ist äh,
die gleiche Frage stellt sich hier natürlich auch. Hat sich ein anonymer Hacker auch gestellt? Und hat bei Vitec äh eingehackt ist da eingeritten.
Ist da eingeritten?
So, der hat, der hat irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, wietec macht, glaube ich, da geht's irgendwie um um so ein Kindertablet. Die haben ähm haben irgendwie so so ein Kindertablett gemacht, wo dann die,
Kid Connect äh irgendwie die Kinder mit ihren Eltern chatten können. Also du bist Kind, hast du ein Tech-Tablet und dieses wie Tech-Tablet,
hatten hatten Messaging, Dienst oder so mit Communication Dienst, mit deinen Eltern und die betreibt die haben da wahrscheinlich eine App für, so ungefähr stelle ich mir das vor. Ich kaufe ja viel, aber äh,
Das nicht?
Und der Typ hat sich da ein bisschen oder die Person hat sich ein bisschen auf dem Server von denen umgeschaut, hat irgendwie Daten von fünfhundert Millionen Eltern und zweihunderttausend Kindern gefunden.
Und da waren dann irgendwie so Namen, E-Mail-Adressen, Passwörter und auch sogar Heimatressen, also,
Adressen, so in der realen Welt. Ähm.
Und dann hat er noch ein bisschen weiter geschaut und hat irgendwie Fotos von Kindern und zwischen Kindern und Eltern gefunden, also dieser Messaging Dienst vollständig äh unverschlüsselt,
ähm auf diesem Server und äh da hat er irgendwie so um die hundertneunzig Gigabyte Bilder runtergeladen,
Und äh von irgendwie zwei Komma drei Millionen Nutzern, die eben diesen Kid-Connect-Dienst nutzen,
viele tausende Fotos von Eltern, Kindern, die sie sich vielleicht auch geschickt haben, ihre Profilbilder,
oder hat irgendwie so ein paar tausend einfach mal äh auch den Journalisten gegeben, um zu zeigen, dass er sie hat,
Er hat jetzt keinerlei Interesse, diese Daten irgendwie zu veröffentlichen oder zu verkaufen, aber möchte halt auf diese eklatanten Zustände da ähm hinweisen. Und ich denke, das ist auch relativ ähm,
Klar, dass die Zustände so sind, weil da kommen ähm da kommen Firmen aus Bereichen, die bisher nix mit,
Vernetzung und so und smart zu tun hatten und sagen, ah ja, okay, wir nehmen jetzt mal hier.
Wir bauen jetzt mal hier sowas und dann holen sie sich halt Leute, die sagen, ja klar, bauen wir. Und,
Die Leute, die mit sowas Erfahrung haben, die vor allem mit der kompetenten und sicheren,
oder sicher rehren, Implementierung von solchen Scherzen Erfahrung haben, die sind natürlich gerade äh schon längst bei anderen Unternehmen, ja und fangen jetzt nicht an, irgendwie so eine.
Und kümmern sich um die richtigen Probleme.
Irgendwelche Audio-Files hat er auch noch auf diesem Server gefunden, da scheinen irgendwie äh Aufzeichnungen der der Stimmen von den Kindern zu sein. Da ist ihm irgendwie noch ganz unklar, ob die da jetzt hingehört haben auf den Server oder auch nicht.
Also da passiert jetzt genau das, was vorhersagbar war,
dass diese ganzen Pfingst jetzt eben nach und nach alle erstmal um die Ohren fliegen. Und das wird eben auch so ähm.
Eine Zeit lang noch so weitergehen.
Ja, Internet of Things, das ist wirklich die programmierte Vollkatastrophe, also das,
Ich will nicht von den Kühlschränken anfangen, aber du hast das eben schon im Prinzip angedeutet, dieses,
gibt da ein Problem. Und das Problem ist, dass diese ganze Security-Kultur einfach noch nicht breit gelebt wird, weil es einfach noch nicht,
genug ja also wahrscheinlich muss das alles auch jetzt erstmal passieren
um einfach überhaupt erstmal in dieser äh auch in der Technikgesellschaft, also auch in diesen betroffenen Unternehmen überhaupt erstmal äh ein Bewusstsein dafür zu bekommen. Manche haben das schon, manche sind ja auch schon lange dabei, Firmen wie Microsoft
Apple die ganzen großen Google und so weiter den ist sehr wohl bewusst was sie dafür Herausforderungen haben und welche Bedeutung das auch für ihre Geschäftsmodelle hat.
Aber diese ganzen Quereinsteiger aus anderen Branchen, das sehen wir ja immer wieder, wenn sich solche Unternehmen dann äh tummeln, ja, seien's Verlage, seien's äh,
Musikbranche, was auch immer sie jegliche Branche, die irgendwann in diese Situation kommt, so oh weia. Äh jetzt müssen wir bei diesem Internet mitmachen, jetzt können wir das nicht weiter äh ignorieren und dann sich schnell aber auch in so einen Rausch ja, so äh wir im Internet
Ja, unsere Visitenkarte. Mein Name auf einem. Das ähm macht, bringt die dann so in Wallung, dass sie dann auch irgendwie alles haben wollen. Und natürlich diese ganze,
Schichte nicht drauf haben. Und das Ganze erweitert sich jetzt durch dieses Internet, durch diese totale
Maximal Miniaturisierung, ja? Wir haben jetzt hier gerade den neuen irgendwie fünf Dollar äh Computer, ja, kompletter äh Rechner mit allem, was man so braucht, äh auf so einem mini Chip für wenig Geld.
Das heißt, wir werden jetzt so eine Phase haben, das wird sich wahrscheinlich jetzt mal locker so fünf bis zehn Jahre lang hinziehen, wo dieser Wahn alles zu elektronisieren, voll abgeht, ja und,
Alles wird irgendwie WLAN haben und alles wird irgendwie erreichbar sein und alles soll irgendwie noch eine Cloud hinten rangedockt bekommen, bis einfach der Schaden so enorm ist,
dass es langsam auch wieder zurückgefahren wird, auf ein Level der ähm ja, weiß ich nicht, halbwegs noch mitzuverantworten ist.
Ja, ich finde, also ich muss andererseits sagen, so, ich habe eine Zahnbürste mit Bluetooth. Ich habe die Heizung, natürlich.
Ist nicht dein Ernst. Natürlich. Machst eine Zahnbürste mit Blutwurst? Warum?
Nähert Bluetooth. Weil kaum noch eine Zahnbürste ohne Bluetooth kriegst. Ja. Das ist ein elektrische Zahnbürste, nicht?
Ja, wozu hat sie plus.
Ich bin noch nicht fertig, Tim, ich habe noch, ich habe noch viel mehr, um dich staunen zu machen. Ich habe in meiner äh Siebträger Kaffeemaschine ähm,
ein äh Temperaturregulationsmodul nachgerüstet mit Bluetooth und App, damit ich mein meine äh meine.
Maschine schon mal auf Temperatur bringen kannst.
Damit die einfach Temperatur stabiler ist. Die war vorher mit so äh Bi-Metall-Schaltern, hat hier halt im Cassy-Temperatur gehalten. Dann so ein paar Grad Schwankungen und jetzt hat sie aufgrund eines äh ausgeklügelten Konzeptes irgendwie so hinterm Komma,
nochmal so leichte Temperaturinstabilitäten.
Und ich kann die Temperatur genaustens einstellen und so ein Kram. Habe ich auch gemacht. Und ich habe auch äh die Heizung, soll ich mal in der Wohnung wärmer machen? Kann ich auch mit einer App.
Rally. Du Fuchs.
Aber ich habe das natürlich alles selbst gemacht,
So gebaut, dass ich nicht an irgendeiner Cloud hänge, äh die eine Fernbedienung dafür hat, sondern ich habe irgendwie äh
die Dienste bei mir im Netz laufen, habe einen VPN dahin und habe das irgendwie alles mal so nach,
was man so lernt über solche Sachen ein bisschen abgedichtet.
Nach bestem Wissen und Gewissen.
Nach bestem Wissen und Gewissen, ja.
Ja und das äh beste, also das beste Wissen, glaube ich, bringt diese Firmen schon zum Einsatz. Das ist bloß halt nicht so gut. Und das Gewissen, da kann man noch dran arbeiten, also äh da ist auf jeden Fall noch Luft nach oben.
Erde. Also ich meine, das ist ja auch cool.
Classers, es es ist alles cool, aber es ist, äh, ich sage ja nur, sie drehen jetzt alle total durch
und und äh haben einfach diese, wie wir das ja bei Webseiten äh genauso gehabt haben, so alle mussten jetzt irgendwie ins Netz und jetzt stellen sie fest, so oh äh überall Löcher, äh
und ähm da gibt's auch eine Gegenbewegung, das ist mittlerweile akzeptiert, auch dieser HTTPS Geschichte, das das dickt jetzt langsam an. Ich meine, das ist noch nicht so lange her, vier, fünf Jahre, da war sogar Facebook komplett über HTTP,
Das kann man sich jetzt gar nicht mehr vorstellen, ja? Aber das war so
und man muss muss zuerst irgendwie schön öffentlich da die äh ganzen Kies, die unverschlüsselt übers WLAN ging, äh mal raushängen und richtig zeigen mit ja hier, müsstet ihr eigentlich ja auch so wissen, warum macht ihr das nicht einfach mal anders,
immer so tun können,
Dieser Prozess muss da erstmal eingeleitet werden, hat stattgefunden und jetzt äh ist es im Prinzip auch erforderlich.
Würde ich zum Beispiel sagen, elektronische Spielzeuge, die gehen jetzt nicht mehr weg, ja?
Aber die halt dann auch so eine Cloud äh haben, die müssen dann einfach auch mal einen gewissen Kodex erfüllen. Also da ist mindestens eine Selbstverpflichtung, wenn nicht sogar eine ähm entsprechende Vorschrift äh am Start
Wenn jetzt hier solche potentiell privaten Daten
ähm gespeichert werden von diesen Geräten auf irgendwelchen Clouds, die man nicht äh unter seiner eigenen hat, dass dann ja einfach eine Regelung erforderlich ist. Ähm,
Bis hin zu verpflichtenden Audits oder was weiß ich. Mal sehen.
Will es auch nicht jedem gleich äh das tolle Businessmodell kaputt machen, aber so geht's halt auch nicht.
Also man sollte sich da wirklich ein bisschen also es ist nicht nur ein also es ist erstens ein IT-Security-Ding, klar, aber es ist auch irgendwie,
Ich finde diesen, diese, dieses Ding halt, es sind Sensoren der Cloud, das finde ich sollte man sich echt in in Erinnerung rufen, ja. Also sagt irgendwie, er hat in diesem in dieser Auswertung von Marco Maas.
Steckdosen, ja, die smarten Steckdosen, die können an- und ausgehen und wenn sie besonders smart sind, können sie vielleicht noch den Strom äh Durchsatz messen,
Tauschen teilweise mehr als sechs MB pro Tag mit der Cloud aus. Die WLAN Lampen von Philips mehr als ein MB und irgendwie die Thermostate.
Ja, die Heizungsthermostate, gut sieben MB.
Und da fragst du dich echt, was für Daten sollen das denn sein? Das Ding hat doch nur ein paar Zustände und vielleicht eine Temperatur? Na ja, also da da sind, glaube ich, äh tja.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das so gut ist.
Ja, das aber nicht die Netzdrossel kommen.
Gleich nutzen.
Schöne Überleitung, oder?
Sollen wir das, ja, machen wir das Thema jetzt, oder? Ähm also was nicht geht.
Die kommt ja jetzt. Lange angekündigt.
Vodafone Kabel zieht jetzt endlich die Drossel an. Die hatten im Prinzip schon seit längerer Zeit in ihrer ähm in ihren AGBs stehen, dass sie nach zehn Gigabyte drosseln.
Also Vodafone hat ja Kabel Deutschland gekauft, muss man dazu sagen. Es geht jetzt hier ums Kabelgeschäft von Vodafone, nicht ums Mobilfunk. System.
Die haben aber bisher üblicherweise erst so bei sechzig Gigabyte gedrosselt. Hatten aber wohl in den AGB schon länger zehn Gigabyte stehen.
Es war sozusagen eine einseitige Freistellung von äh von Vodafone und Kabel Deutschland gegenüber den Gründen, ja, also man kann das muss sich ja auch alles erstmal entwickeln, ja, der der Durst muss ja überhaupt erstmal auch äh entstehen, ja, nach diesen ganzen Angeboten
und wenn er dann da ist, dann äh fällt die Klappe. Das ist jetzt soweit.
Und das ist jetzt genau das ist geschehen. Jetzt sagen sie äh ab zehn ähm Gigabyte ist Feierabend. Und.
Diese zehn Gigabyte beziehen sich aber nur auf Foilsharing,
Und jetzt stellt sich aber natürlich die Frage, okay, was ist ein File-Sharing, ne? Was ist denn, wenn ich jetzt mal eine Lähnungsdistribution runterlade über Bittorent, rassel ich dann in diese,
in dieses Problem rein oder nicht? Ja, was also wann greift diese Drossel,
Und da hat einer äh einer unserer Hörer mal versucht nachzufragen,
gesagt, ja ich würde ja schon ganz gerne wissen, was da so passiert.
Genau, weil das ist so sein Businessanschluss und da ist er irgendwie am äh Webdevelopen und ist ja, sagen wir mal, alle Dienste auch durchaus äh relevant,
Ja und da kam so äh der Support. Ja, was was würde denn da genau gedrosselt werden? Ja, Falschharing. Aha, das ist aber jetzt nicht sehr genau,
Vielleicht bestimmte Ports? Nein, nein, generell. Aha. Und was wird nicht gedrosselt? Ja, surfen und E-Mail und Video-Streaming.
Surfen ist geil, oder? Surfen, super.
Ja und dann kam halt so ein bisschen der Hinweis, so ja hier äh Businesskunde und irgendwie, das kann ja wohl nicht angehen, dass sie mir nicht klar sagen können, was denn sozusagen jetzt hier äh Sache ist. Ich habe ja hier schließlich einen Vertrag mit euch und ähm,
Irgendwie müsste er mal die Gegenseite auch die Konditionen mal klar definieren können. Dann kam so die Aussage, na ja, VPN,
Und SSH äh würden ja nicht äh gedrosselt werden, ne? Weil das ist ja sozusagen das, was Businesskunden brauchen
Vodafone Sicht, wahrscheinlich auch ganz erklärbar. Weißt du, das sind so die Leute, die dann aufm Flughafen sich mal eben nochmal äh in ihr Firmennetz äh einbuchen,
ne? Das ist sozusagen das, ne? Aber äh das HTTP und das FDP äh Protokoll, na ja, äh das schon auch irgendwie, aber nur bei bestimmten äh Servern, also nicht bei allen, ne, also,
One Clique und äh wahrscheinlich sowas wie Repicer, aber so genau wissen sie's auch nicht und ob das jetzt auch,
betrifft oder Google Drive und so, hm, ja, nee, wissen wir nicht. Äh, ja. Nichts Genaues weiß man nicht. Das ist schon mal sehr interessant.
Touchiert ja auch noch sehr viel mehr Bereiche als jetzt nur diese reine Drosseldiskussion, die ja bisher sozusagen nur über das Volumen geht, sondern hier merkt man, zumindest,
bei dieser für meinen Geschmack doch sehr uninformierten äh Auskunft des Supportdienstes, also ich weiß nicht, also hier müsste man, glaube ich, irgendjemand mal entlassen werden, äh wahrscheinlich weniger diese Person, sondern vielmehr die Person, die,
dafür sorgt, dass Zeug
Aussagen, solche unklaren Aussagen überhaupt getroffen werden, keine Ahnung oder vielleicht auch diejenigen, die tatsächlich diese, wenn das so der Realität entspricht, eben diese auch äh äh,
entsprechend angewiesen hat, weil irgendwie muss ja mal die Dienstleistung auch ganz klar,
definiert werden und wenn es so ist, dann äh sieht es ja auch so aus, als ob das gegen die neuen,
die neu beschlossene Netzneutralität, die sogenannte äh auf EU-Ebene verstößt, wo ja sozusagen das Sperrend und Drosseln von bestimmten Diensten nun auch explizit untersagt ist, also so viel wir an Kritik geäußert haben gegenüber dieser Regelung, dass es da zumindest drin.
Ja, also liebe Kabel Deutschland Kunden hier äh und da sagen Hörerinnen und Hörern äh,
Ich würde mal da vorstellig werden bei dem Unternehmen und vielleicht mal die selbe Diskussion führen, das äh könnte ganz ergiebig sein, also sozusagen nicht unbedingt in den einzelnen Gespräch sehr ergiebig, aber so in der Summe aller Gespräche Düsseldorf scheint ganz äh ergiebig sein,
insbesondere, wenn man mal schaut, wie viel unterschiedliche Aussagen es dann letzten Endes gibt. Oder eben auch nur die fehlenden Aussagen.
Falsche.
Wir wissen schon Bescheid,
Ja
Und wir erinnern uns bei dieser ganzen Drosselei, geht's ja am Ende weniger darum, uns irgendwie.
In unserer Bandbreitennutzung,
zu begrenzen, sondern in der Art der Bandbreitennutzung. Denn wer jetzt irgendwie den ganzen Tag lang Netflix schaut, der wird ja nicht gedrosselt.
Und es ist also genau diese Bevormundung und in diesem Fall eine intransparente Bevormundung,
die da passiert und da ist natürlich ein Wort im Raume und das ist das Wort der Netzneutralität. Und da gab es jetzt eine sehr,
Interessante und auch sehr gut formulierte Mitteilungen von Hetzner. Hetzner ist ein Anbieter von,
ja eigentlich Server holt man sich bei Hetzner oder? Also sie haben wahrscheinlich auch irgendwelche anderen äh Hosting-Geschichten oder so, aber üblicherweise geht man zu Hetzner und holt sich ein,
Hm ein Server.
Also üblicherweise man geht auch zu anderen äh Anbietern. Genau.
Holt man sich da üblicherweise einen Server, ja. Die haben äh glaube ich ganz günstige Preise. Ähm weil sie Consumer Hardware einsetzen, also sowas. Ist auch völlig egal.
Ja, also ist auf jeden Fall ein rein konkurrenzfähiges Angebot und wird von vielen wahrgenommen. Nicht, dass wir das jetzt hier in Dorsen wollen oder so, waren, ist halt einfach so. Hetzener ist einfach einer, der größeren, ganz großen, wenn nicht sogar der größte in Deutschland.
Und die sagen, die haben natürlich, also die haben Unmengen an Servern da stehen und an äh Virtual Servern und Hosting Geschichten, die sie darauf laufen lassen und die sind natürlich dann auch äh straff ans Internet angebunden und sagen.
Aktuell werden etwa zwei Drittel unseres Netzverkehrs direkt über kostenneutrale Peerings vieler verschiedener Partner ausgetauscht.
Darunter befindet sich auch eine Reihe privater Peerings mit großen Netzbetreibern. Das ist also so, hetzender Städter und hat irgendwie viele äh Server da stehen,
Internetprovider steht irgendwo anders und sagt, ey Mensch Hetzner, so wir sehen, wir haben irgendwie so und so viel äh Traffic äh bei euch. Unsere Nutzer wollen eure Sachen sehen,
Lasst uns doch mal, wenn wir eh hier grade beim beim DKX liegen, lass uns doch mal Kabel rüberlegen und dann knoten wir unsere Dinger aneinander und dann können wir da direkt flott äh den Zugang ermöglichen. So, von unseren Kunden zu euren, euren, weil da liegt ja, da geht's ja offenbar
Bedarf, ja? Und da wird halt, da ist nix weiter nötig, als das eben
mal miteinander telefonieren und sich darauf einigen, äh wie sie die, wie sie ihre rotigen Tabellen schreiben und welches
Kabel oder welchen Lichtquellenleiter sie sie wo rüber legen. Ja, das kostet nichts. Da verlangt auch niemand von dem anderen Geld für, weil es etwas ist, was im Interesse beider ist.
Schnelle Verbindungen.
Und so wurde auch der größere Teil des Internets immer gebaut und so waren auch alle immer happy. Und jetzt,
schreibt wir beobachten mit wachsender Sorge.
DSL und Kabelanbieter, welche einerseits selbst keine offene Peeringpolicy betreiben.
Aber auch andererseits nicht mit ausreichender Kapazität zu anderen Tier-eins-Karrieren angebunden sind.
Also Tier eins heißt Top Level, da wo die richtig fetten Bandbreiten gefahren werden.
Die richtig dicken, wo dann irgendwie Level sieben Level seven oder so was. Die Großen.
Betreiber des fetten Internets, ja? Und wenn du halt kein direktes Peering mit sagen wir mal der deutschen Telekom hast, ja? Dann.
Oder halt Kabel Deutschland.
Oder Kabel Deutschland.
Mal, das sind so die beiden, die hier im Wesentlichen genannt werden.
Dann knotest du dich eben hast du noch diesen Level sieben,
hast du halt irgendwie noch einen großen Zugang, über den du dann dieses andere Drittel machst. Ärgerlicherweise kostet der dich ein bisschen Geld oder so, kann also level seven gibt dir das nicht für Oma?
Und deswegen bist du halt, da ist es für alle in aller Leuts Interesse einfach schön zu pieren,
den Rest irgendwie über diese normalen äh großen zu abzuwickeln. Und jetzt kritisiert Hetzner und sagt, naja, diese Kabel und DSL-Provider sind aber bei den
Auch nicht mit ausreichender Kapazität angebunden.
Was heißt mit ausreichender Kappe, nicht mit ausreichender Kapazität angebunden? Das heißt, die haben Traffic-Probleme, Zustoßzeiten.
Und da sagt auch Hetz, na ja, wir sehen also jetzt hier ähm,
dass zwischen zu den Hauptverkehrszeiten, zwischen neunzehn und zweiundzwanzig Uhr die betroffenen DSL und Kabelanbieter an ihre Kapazitätsgrenzen stoßen und somit den flüssigen Datenaustausch zwischen den einzelnen Netzen ähm,
behindern. Ja, die könnten natürlich jetzt einfach sagen, ah okay, Mist, wir gehen zu viel über Tier eins,
Lasse auch markieren und genau das schlagen die ja dann auch vor. Allerdings haben die eine.
Nicht so promiskoetive Peering Policy und sagen, wir wollen ganz gerne Geld dafür sehen. Denn es sind ja unsere Kunden, die Probleme haben, deine Server zu erreichen.
Das könnte ja schlecht für dein Geschäftsmodell sein.
Oder beziehungsweise oder es sind ja deine Kunden, die Probleme haben, unsere zu erreichen.
Mhm. Schönes Geschäftsmodell.
Und er sagt, sagt, äh Hetzner zurecht, ähm.
Die Kunden haben durch ihr monatliches, äh, durch ihre monatlichen Gebühren den Netzbetreiber für einen umfassenden und schnellen Zugang zum Internet bezahlt.
Die Anbieter möchten jedoch neben den Einkünften, die sie von ihren Endkunden bekommen, weitere Einnahmen für den Zugang zu Content-Anbietern erzielen.
Als Headsner Online GmbH möchten wir eine derartige Geschäftspraxis eigentlich nicht unterstützen und sprechen uns für umfängliche Netzneutralität aus. Gleichzeitig haben sie aber ein starke Nachfrage ihrer Kunden,
auf eine performante Anbindung ins Netz der deutschen Telekom, zu zu den genannten Zeiten. Und da sagen sie, okay, für diese Kunden, die das haben wollen, bieten wir jetzt,
Ein extra Abling zur deutschen Telekom an für fünf Euro im Monat,
Und auf dem läuft das Gleiche äh Traffic-Volumen, was ihr eh für eure Server habt und äh wenn ihr diese Grenze überschreitet, kostet vier Euro siebzehn pro Terabyte äh mehr.
So, da haben wir hier sozusagen den Wegzoll.
Da haben wir den Weg voll. Da haben wir genau den Weg Zoll. Und ich finde es, es ist ein es ist gut.
Und.
Und traurig, dass Hetzer diesen Schritt geht und sagt, wir zahlen den nicht,
Wir machen's unseren Kunden möglich, aber wir machen nicht möglich, ohne euch mal irgendwie zu zeigen, was das hier für eine Scheiße ist. So und jetzt redest du nämlich von fünf Euro im Monat für die Deutsche Telekom.
Lasst die Deutsche Telekom, äh dreißig, vierzig Prozent Marktdurchdringung haben in deiner Zielgruppe, dann hast du immer noch die anderen,
Und die werden jetzt auch kommen und sich sagen? Seid ihr ein Fünfer? Tja, ähm, hm, aber so bei uns doch vielleicht auch.
Sind eigentlich unsere Kapazitäten zu hetzen, aber die sind ja vielleicht viel zu groß, wenn wir die nämlich kleiner machen, dann entsteht ja da auch sehr viel mehr Druck.
Also dieses ganze Argument, in dieser Netzneutralitätsdebatte, was von den äh Lobbyisten für die aktuelle Regelung, also jetzt getroffene Regelung
geführt wurde, war ja immer so, na ja, man muss ja sozusagen die Investitionen für den Netzausbau auch irgendwie finanzieren und deswegen muss es ja möglich sein, solche Spezialdienste zu machen. Was aber hier zu einem Spezialdienst verkommt, ist der pure
Zugang zu den Diensten und äh führt,
umgekehrt auch noch dazu, dass hier ein ein finanzieller Anreiz geschaffen wurde eben keine Ausbauten zu machen,
In dem Moment, wo man gesagt hätte, nee, dürft ihr alles nicht machen, alles ist einfach Netz, ihr leitet durch, seht zu, dass ihr eure Kosten, über eure Kunden reinbekommt. Das hätte einen offenen Wettbewerb aufgemacht,
Und äh man würde dadurch glänzen, dass man eben schnellere Verbindungen hat.
Meine Befürchtung ist, dass das jetzt noch nicht mal die die aktuelle äh Netzneutralitätsentscheidung,
berührt. Also, es handelt sich hier nicht um einen Spezialdienst. Das ist auch eine Praxis, die die Deutsche Telekom schon länger und vorher immer gemacht hat und das Generelle Interesse der Netzanbieter gewesen, dass sie halt sagen,
Ach sopieren mit uns ja da müssen wir euch ein Angebot schicken. Ja das das machen die,
Das meine ich schon länger, ja. Also hier, es ist jetzt nicht ein,
Spezialdienst, den die Deutsche Telekom jetzt ihren Nutzern anbietet, diese ganze Netzwerksregulierung wurde ja auch eher aus der Konsumentenperspektive,
ähm immer wieder geführt. Und wir reden ja aber hier von der Perspektive des Content-Anbieters.
Na gut, aber erinnern wir uns an die Diskussion. Kurz nach Veröffentlichung dieser neuen Regelung, also nach dem Schluss kam ja dann die Telekom in Form ihres äh Chefs mit der,
im schönen Blogposting, was wir hier auch,
haben. So äh äh so mit na ja, Start-ups brauchen ja sozusagen auch einen beschleunigten äh Zugang zu ihren Kunden, ja, das läuft schon so ein bisschen über diese Denkweise und legitimiert im Prinzip genau solche Sachen.
Und da wird die Telekom natürlich genau so was machen. Da werden sie genau das Gleiche machen so ah schöne Startup haben sie das. Ruck ruckelt nur ein bisschen.
Aber wir können ja ein paar Anteile bekommen,
Und dann fällt auch echt von der Decke auf einmal so ein Lichtwellenleiter, dann steckt sie da hinten dran. Da habt ihr aber im Netz der deutsch, im besten Netz, habt ihr dann auch beste Bits?
Und das ist eine Geschäftspraktik, die allem zuwiderstrebt, was in diesem Netz Grundgedanke war. Über Jahrzehnte.
Und das wird die Deutsche Telekom nämlich genau nicht mit den Großen machen. Sie machen's genau mit Hetzen, aber sie wissen, okay, Hetzner ist ein großer, großer äh Hoster, aber die Content-Anbieter dort sind wenige und ich bin sehr, also ich finde es.
Ich finde es gut, dass oder ja, ich finde es im Ergebnis gut, dass Hetzner das auch so mit Kritik verbindet und sagt so, ey, wir wollen das nicht, wir finden das scheiße,
Aber wir müssen, weil unsere Kunden danach fragen und es wird jetzt halt eine Option geben und die kostet Geld und es dauert einen Tag die einzurichten, aber ich find's.
Aber man macht zumindest auch klar, wo das Problem liegt, ne? Weil es ist explizit der der deutsche Telekom AG Zuschlag und so heißt er auch und äh ja.
Und sie nennen's auch Double Pay Traffic.
Es ist super.
Was natürlich was geiles, ja, der ist doppelt bezahlt. Den haben andere schon mal bezahlt, weil du.
Auch nochmal.
Doppelzahlen an die Deutsche Telekom machst du hier Klick so.
Hast du double Pay.
Machen, dann kriegst du noch äh Kabel Deutschland. Ja und das ist, also ich meine, es ist auch immens, überleg mal, fünf Euro für einen so einen Klecker Provider.
Weißt du was, das Schlimme ist, Tim? Da könnte ja jeder kommen.
Da wird doch jetzt jeder kommen.
Wird doch jetzt hier da kommen.
Ja, das ist auch super. Ich meine, ihr stellt euch dann sozusagen schon mal so ein auf so, so, so, so ein freies äh äh
Ja, das Internet ist sozusagen so ein Wald, da sind die Räuber und äh alle, äh die sozusagen irgendwo an so einem Weg stehen, wo man was äh amtlich erreichen kann. Die werden dann einfach alle nochmal so nach eigenem Gutdünken
entsprechende Gelder aufnimmt. So skaliert natürlich ein Netz nicht und so skaliert auch keine Innovation und das ist halt einfach genau das Gegenteil von äh freier Startup Kultur,
das ist sozusagen etwas, wo jeder erstmal darüber nachdenken muss, wie viel ähm Backschisch er da sozusagen noch mit ins Feld führen muss, um überhaupt äh erreichbar zu sein. Und wer hat da
äh sein Benefit davon, die Großen, die etablierten Dienste. Genau die, die man eigentlich durch Dysruption äh am Kochen halten muss.
Willkommen im freien Restnetz der Deutschen Telekom.
Das ist so unschön.
Ja
Dafür wird's jetzt auch mal ein bisschen sichtbar und vielleicht äh wird das die nächste Runde der Diskussion, die wir hier auf jeden Fall auch noch miterleben werden, mindestens bereits sind anzuregen, dann auch entsprechend beeinflussen. Ist ja nicht so, dass nicht auch schon mal äh Trends wieder zurückgenommen wurden.
Ne
Ja? Ich habe den Eindruck, bestimmte Trends.
Erinner dich, wir haben auch irgendwie Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung, wo du groß bekannt gegeben, zwei Tage nach Pariser Anschlägen, so fand ich jetzt ähm in Deutschland, na ja klar, wir reden ja hier von Deutschland.
In Deutschland. Hm na ja. Wie gesagt, das äh diese äh Ende zu Ende Geschichte, die kriegen wir nächstes Jahr mit einem schönen Staatstrojaner. Äh ja, aber locker mit der Mütze.
Wieder um die Ohren gehauen. Sicherlich, der Kampf geht weiter.
Der Kampf geht weiter. So.
So, schauen wir doch mal auf die internationalen äh Ereignisse, dass wir uns hier nicht immer nur im deutschen Sumpf bewegen.
Wir haben über den Fall mehrmals berichtet, den Fall von Nicoles Mirri, der mit dem äh Kerlex ein ähm,
Ein Internetprovider in den in New York hatte und dann einen National Security Letter bekommen hatte.
Und in diesem stand ja irgendwie so drin, gib mal die Daten und
Red mit niemandem drüber und äh wir haben auch mehrfach schon seinen Talk beim siebenundzwanzig C drei äh resisting excessiv Governments Valence,
Empfohlen empfohlen das an dieser Stelle nochmal und wir haben auch schon vor einigen Folgen davon berichtet, dass
er seinen äh Court Case da jetzt gewonnen hat, nämlich den um die Transparenz und dann musst du noch eine zeitliche Frist ablaufen bis er diesen National Security Letter veröffentlichen darf.
Und das hat er dann auch getan. Und wir sehen gar haarsträubende Dinge darin stehen.
Ähm in denen das FBI eben sagt, ja wir möchten die komplette Webbrowsing History.
IP-Adressen, von allen Personen, mit denen diese Person kommuniziert hat.
Eine Liste aller Online-Käufe,
Und so weiter, also alles auch Dinge, die du jetzt nicht unbedingt erwarten würdest, dass ein äh Internetprovider die bereithalten kann, vielleicht zu dieser Zeit schon, weil da noch weniger ähm,
Traffic ähm,
Übers Internet lief. Äh äh Traffic verschlüsselt war, aber sie sagen so, DSL Accountinformation, Radio, also den den Anmeldeserver, ähm.
Screennames Online,
irgendwie so einmal alles, ja?
Wollen sie haben und er hat jetzt aber endlich diesen, ich meine, der Mann hat, weiß ich nicht, wie viel Jahre jetzt gekämpft, sechs, sieben Jahre, ja, eine elf, elf Jahre hat er, hat er gegen diese Angelegenheit gekämpft, die letzten Jahre öffentlich und es ist äh ein.
Einfach nur dem dem Durchsetzungswillen dieses Mannes zu verdanken, dass er dass wir diesen National Security Letter jetzt mal sehen können.
Und das FBI verschickt mehrere zehntausend davon pro Jahr,
An Internetservice Provider, Autohändler, Versicherungen, Ärzte, egal wen. Insgesamt zwischen zweitausenddrei und zweitausendfünf.
Einhundertdreiundvierzigtausend und vierundsiebzig National Security Letters.
Und Nick Mary sagt natürlich auch so ja, also das das FBI hat diese Autorität der International Security Letters irgendwie
vollständig ausgehöhlt und irgendwie auf unsere Websuchen die Menschen, mit denen wir sprechen, die die Orte, die wir besuchen, ausgedehnt und das trifft natürlich den,
Was man in Deutschland den den Kernbereich, der der äh Privatheit äh nennt, inklusive unserer politischen Aktivitäten, unserer Religion, unserer persönlichen Beziehung,
Und teilweise auch unserer privaten Gedanken und äh das ist natürlich so nicht gut,
Aber ne, das Problem wird ja jetzt gelöst. Schon im Januar hat ja Barack Obama äh gesagt, okay, wir möchten jetzt ähm diese Gag-Orders, um die es nämlich insbesondere hier ging, nicht nur darum, dass diese Informationen,
Bereitgestellt werden sollen, sondern auch, dass man nicht darüber sprechen darf. Dass die ein Verfallsdatum,
bekommen sollen. Das ist jetzt die Heilung, ja? Sie können das immer noch verschicken, aber die die Geheimhaltungspflicht sollte erstmal ein Verfallsdatum bekommen. Ja? Allerdings.
Wenn.
Ein ähm Special Agent oder ein Director feststellen, dass ähm die Voraussetzungen für die Geheimhaltung,
Weiter bestehen, dann darf diese,
Geheimhaltung auch erweitert werden.
Es muss einfach nochmal eine Hierarchieebene höher, äh nochmal einer seinen Larry drunter setzen, damit die Sache noch länger geheim gehalten werden kann.
Kann ja nicht sein. Ne, also.
Eigentlich kann nicht sein, dass das jetzt auf einmal wirklich äh dann frei ist.
Also was ganz schön ist, ist äh es gibt eine eine Sache hier, die müssen schriftlich begründen, warum
welche Bedingungen erfüllt sind und warum eine weitere Geheimhaltung ähm gerechtfertigt ist. Man stellt sich jetzt vor, dass die abends da sitzen müssen und argumentieren müssen, aber man weiß, äh dass es für alle Beteiligten
schöner und schneller geregelt ist. Ne, dieser gesamte,
Behördenakt ist schneller erledigt, wenn man einen Vordruck hat, Datum und Name einträgt und darauf wird es dann wahrscheinlich auch leider.
Hinauslaufen.
Das sind irgendwie hundertdreißig von diesen Letters pro Tag, wenn das jetzt wirklich vom ersten Januar bis äh letzten Dezember gerechnet wurde.
Ist schon ganz ordentlich. Also, ist jetzt nicht unbedingt so ein Instrument, was ab und zu mal äh an Gewinn.
Das ist ja schon richtig Massenmedien.
Spam.
Spam. Ja, wir haben auch noch ein bisschen Spam, oder?
Ja, du warst, du wolltest äh Podcast empfehlen.
Ja. Ähm durch meine eigenen Empfehlen. Oder andere Leute Podcasts.
Ich kann auch andere Leute Podcast empfehlen. Soll ich anfangen? Ja, ich empfehle ein, ich habe jetzt einen Podcast gehört von äh Bekannten von mir.
Mit dem Namen Metrolaut, das ist der Podcast von Metronaut und ich habe mich letzte Woche mit Kalle Kornblum unterhalten, der dort äh einer der Macher ist, zusammen mit mit John F Nebel,
und ähm wir haben festgestellt, die haben in letzter Zeit echt ganz gute Podcasts gemacht. Es gibt irgendwie einen sehr spannenden über Fluchthilfe
Ja, wo jemand äh Menschen über die Grenze gefahren hat. Es gibt einen über
die Kultur des Dschihad, wo sie irgendwie einen Experten haben und sich so äh IS Videos anschauen und Propaganda äh irgendwie sezieren und sich damit längere Zeit auseinandersetzen.
Klammer auf, krasse Scheiße, klammert zu.
Das ist krasses Scheiß.
Das wird hier ziemlich heftig. Also da solltet ihr mal reinhören. Das äh lässt zwar ja mal nicht so gut schlafen, aber ist auf jeden Fall mal ganz wichtig, sich das mal äh anzutun.
Paar schönen, schönen Analysen, was da sozusagen in diesen Köpfen äh vor sich geht und was unser Anteil äh äh daran ist.
Das fand ich auch echt mal spannend, weil diese ganzen IS-Propagan an Materialien oder so diese Dschihad-Kultur, die eben in dieser Folge oft besprochen wird,
mit der hast du ja sonst nichts am Hut. Die hörst du nicht, die siehst du nicht. Du liest aber jeden Tag in den Medien ja, die Propaganda des Dschihad und so, ne, müssen wir jetzt irgendwie auch mal mit der Anonymität Anonymität und Hass im Internet und und so, ne, spielt ja auch da alles rein,
Und äh das fand ich auch sehr äh informativ dieses Gespräch, was da mit Arne Vogelgesang geführt wurde,
Ah, die haben auch so andere Sachen irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Graffiti Geschichten oder äh dann waren sie irgendwann mal in Istanbul. Das hat man, glaube ich, auch hier mal erwähnt.
So ein bisschen dein Lieblings-Podcast, ne? Hast du schon häufiger mal erwähnt.
Ich glaube, das ist so ein bisschen mein Lieblings-Podcast, ja.
Okay. War's okay. Was sind deine Lieblingskonzepte?
Was ist denn dein Lieblings-Podcast? Raumzeit, ne? Raumzeit ist aber auch mein Lieblings. Ich habe ja mehrere Lieblings-Podcaste. Raumzeit ist auf jeden Fall auch einer meiner Lieblings-Podcaste.
Genau, das äh vielleicht jetzt machen wir mal so einen kleinen Werbeblog einschreien. Also wer äh noch nicht weiß, was das ist. Raumzahl ist eine Interviewserie,
die ich vor fünf Jahren mal gestartet habe, gemeinsam mit Esa und DDR über Raumfahrt im Allgemeinen und das äh lief ja auch sehr lange und sehr gut. Musste dann aber äh erstmal eingestellt werden, weil,
Da die Finanzierung nicht weiterging und ich hatte mich dann halt in der Zwischenzeit mal umgeschaut nach neuen äh Kooperationspartnern, die habe ich jetzt gefunden und deswegen geht's jetzt weiter mit Raumzeit. Vielleicht noch nicht so in derselben Schlagzahl, aber äh immerhin kontinuierlich, zumindest ist das jetzt der Plan.
Mal sehen, wie das so äh ausgeht. Ja und,
Da könnt ihr gerne mal wieder reinhören oder überhaupt mal reinhören, wenn ihr das noch nicht gemacht habt. Da gibt's jetzt auch eine neue äh Folge, die glaube ich ganz interessant ist. Und für all die Leute, die sich immer wundern, so, ah, hier, Mensch, der Tim und so.
Weil diesmal das und die Zimmer weiter und so weiter. Ich habe keinen Überblick mehr. Dafür habe ich einen Meter Podcast über die Meterebene gemacht. Das haben die Mieter.
Podcast.
Nein, nein.
Rein.
Subvensiver, ne?
Meterebene und ähm findet ihr auf Meterebene ME zum Abonnieren und das sind dann immer so so was weiß ich, alle paar Monate mal fünf Minuten Ansprache von mir, wo ich einfach mal schnell, so wie ich das jetzt auch mache,
über alles rübergehe oder überhaupt mal ein Update zu meinem ganzen äh Programm liefere und immer, wenn's dann neue Sendungen gibt oder wieder Aufnahmen gibt oder Gründe für Einstellungen oder Pausen, dann werde ich das ja kurz thematisieren.
So wie ich das jetzt auch gerade getan habe. Hm. Wieder in diesem Podcast, der jetzt grade mal drei Ausgaben kurze Ausgaben.
Drei Ausgaben und schon eine Empfehlung. Ach so, aber das ist auch.
Aber es hat nur gemerkt, Leute, die halt Podcasts hören, bitte?
Ist aber auch Text auf Metaebene.
Ja, ich blogge da auch, also das ist sozusagen so mein mein Portal. Ich will auch, sagen wir mal, jetzt diese diese Audioverlautbarung nochmal ein bisschen besser äh herausstellen. Das äh braucht noch ein bisschen Arbeit. Aber ich habe halt auch gemerkt, dass Leute, die eben,
In dem Podcast-Programm äh folgen. Solche Änderungen, die man über die man schreibt, dann so nicht ohne Weiteres mitbekommen.
Und ähm deswegen habe ich halt einfach nochmal diesen Meta-Kanal eingeführt, den man quasi abonnieren kann, wie so ein kleines Blog. Das heißt immer, wenn du das wirklich wichtig ist, ist, äh schreibe ich da drüber,
und sprecht das vielleicht aber auch nochmal rein, also habe,
sozusagen beide Kanäle, die ich dann äh befülle, inwiefern ich das jetzt etablieren will, dass ich immer zu jedem Blogartikel auch was in Audio mache, weiß ich noch nicht so ganz genau, könnte äh durchaus angehen. Ich habe bloß auch festgestellt,
Manches lässt sich besser in Text, manches lässt sich besser in Audio formulieren und das äh ja, das muss ich selber noch abwägen.
Mhm.
Ja. Damit entlassen wir euch.
Damit entlassen wir euch so einfach.
Hm. Wir senden noch ein bisschen, ne, vor Jahresende. Haben noch, glaube ich, den einen oder anderen Termin.
Wenn was ist, jederzeit.
Wenn was ist, ne? Wenn was nicht stimmt, sind wir da. Oder halt.
Wir spielen mit unserem äh guten Morgen, Tim. Ich möchte.
Genau. Und wenn wir nicht da sind, dann wählt er einfach eins als neue. Ob der Polizei und dann geht das auch.
Das Video war echt geil. Keine Gedanken.
Äh
Sowas wollen wir auch mal irgendwann ey so.
Volle Props das war wirklich grandios, zwei Fliegen mit einer Klappe, das auch so schneller nach. Okay,
tschüss.
Tschau, tschau.